Salut aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre à prédire une carte à l'avance.
Le dimanche c'est le jour des explications.
Et je ne déroge pas à la règle
puisque ce dimanche je vous apprends
quelque chose qui va vous permettre de bluffer les gens que vous connaissez.
Vous avez juste besoin d'un jeu de cartes,
qu'il soit complet ou pas,
qu'il soit à vous ou pas.
N'importe quel jeu de cartes fera l'affaire.
C'est basé sur deux principes de mentalisme très simples :
un qui est, disons, la grosse embrouille
et un autre qui est la parenthèse d'oubli.
C'est-à-dire qu'après avoir réalisé tout ça,
les souvenirs du spectateur
vont se reformer un petit peu différemment
et il va oublier des moments clés du processus que vous avez fait.
Cette technique elle existe sous plein de formes.
Plein d'auteurs ont travaillé dessus.
J'ai ma propre version.
Tout le monde a sa version de ça.
La première fois que j'en ai eu connaissance
c'est dans ce livre là qui s’appelle psi mentalisme
qui a été traduit par Richard Volmère en 81.
C'est d'ailleurs un des premiers livres de mentalisme que j'ai eu.
Il est sorti avant ma naissance, je ne sais pas si on peut le retrouver encore aujourd'hui.
Vous prenez le jeu de cartes et vous le donnez à mélanger à un spectateur.
Il le mélange comme il veut, entièrement,
complétement, plusieurs fois.
Il peut couper, il fait tout ce qu'il veut.
Une fois que c'est fait, vous lui demandez quand même de faire vérifier
que toutes les cartes sont bien différentes.
Partout dans le jeu et qu'il n'y en a pas deux identiques.
Et vous lui demandez de choisir, dans sa tête, un nombre entre 1 et 52.
en admettant qu'il y ait 52 cartes.
Vous, pendant ce temps là, vous écrivez une petite prédiction quelque part.
Vous écrivez le futur.
On pose le futur ici.
Vous demandez à votre spectateur s'il a bien son nombre en tête,
s'il a bien dit à personne.
Parce que ça c'est très important.
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
il doit compter autant de cartes que son nombre sur la table.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11
S'il a choisi le chiffre 11.
Mais vous, vous ne le savez pas encore à ce moment-là.
Il repose les cartes.
Et c'est seulement à partir de maintenant que vous, vous allez toucher aux cartes.
Vous récupérez les cartes du bout des doigts.
et vous dites la phrase suivante :
"À partir de maintenant je vais vous demander votre nombre
juste pour vérifier que vous avez fait les choses correctement.
C'était quoi?"
Le spectateur répond 11 et là vous comptez très lentement :
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 et 11
Vous ne reposez pas la dernière carte.
C'est votre choix, c'est votre nombre, c'est vous qui l'avez choisi.
Vous avez mélangé les cartes vous-même depuis le départ.
Vous avez choisi ce nombre, vous les avez posées ici.
Et la onzième carte c'est le "7 de coeur".
Et souvenez-vous, avant que vous choisissiez le nombre dans votre tête,
j'avais écrit quelque chose, j'avais écrit le futur juste ici,
et j'avais écrit, évidemment, le 7 de coeur.
Alors oui, ça paraît très osée comme méthode
mais ça fonctionne justement parce que c'est le spectateur qui a les cartes dans les mains.
C'est le spectateur qui mélange les cartes, c'est le spectateur qui choisit un nombre
sans le dire, dans sa tête.
Vous écrivez la prédiction avant qu'il commence à donner les cartes.
Et c'est toutes ces choses, et les phrases précises que j'ai dites précédemment
et que vous allez vous aussi dire quand vous ferez votre présentation
qui vont faire que dans son souvenir, vous n'avez touché à rien.
C'est pas tout-à-fait vrai.
Et plus le temps passera
plus il aura aussi comme souvenir que vous avez écrit la prédiction
avant de commencer le tour.
Vous n'êtes pas obligé d'écrire une prédiction d'ailleurs.
Vous pourriez garder cette information là pour vous,
lui demander de prendre connaissance de cette carte-là secrètement
et vous après vous pouvez imaginer le tour que vous voulez
en ayant vous-même connaissance de cette carte.
Comment ça se passe?
Et bien techniquement vous récupérerez tout mon texte.
Exactement, mot-à-mot.
Toute ma manière de procéder.
Comme je vous l'ai dit, c'est une embrouille
et une espèce de parenthèse d'oubli à l'intérieur.
Donc il faut être assez précis pour que tout ça se passe très bien.
Le point culminant pour vous, qui va vous faire prendre connaissance de la carte.
C'est une fois que la personne a mélangé
ou vous récupérez le jeu, ou vous lui demandez de bien faire vérifier que toutes les cartes sont différentes
et à partir de ce moment-là, vous devez prendre connaissance de la première carte,
de la première carte du paquet.
Donc celle qui est tout à la gauche de la personne qui tient le paquet.
Si c'est vous qui tenez le paquet,
passez la juste rapidement.
C'est un peu comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure dans la démonstration.
Et une fois que c'est fait, vous comprenez que c'est bien logique
puisque la carte est ici.
Si moi je choisis 5 dans ma tête, je compte :
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Je repose le paquet.
Vous, vous récupérez les cartes.
Et sous prétexte de vérifier que tout à été fait correctement,
vous allez demander le nombre à la personne.
Donc 5 en l'occurrence
et 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Vous venez juste d'annuler ce qu'il vient de faire.
Donc vous récupérez sur le dessus du paquet, la carte que VOUS vous aviez regardé précédemment.
Ça ne paraît rien mais prenez le temps de répéter ça,
de bien vous mettre tout ça en tête
que ce soit très précis pour vous, très fluide, très logique
de bien avoir les phrases pour en faire une belle présentation.
Si vous faites ça correctement, ce sera bluffant.
Ne le faites pas deux fois d'affilée, ça ne marchera pas.
Faites-le qu'une fois à une personne.
Mettez-le bien en scène.
Et faites-vous plaisir.
Bluffez vos amis, bluffez votre famille.
Imaginez une histoire autour et faites-vous plaisir.
De ma propre expérience, je peux vous dire "ça fonctionne",
et ça bluffe les gens.
Et en plus c'est drôle à faire.
Et puis si cette explication-là ou ce genre de tour vous plaît,
n'hésitez pas, dites-le moi dans les commentaires.
Je les lis TOUS, n'oubliez pas.
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne avec le pouce en l'air.
pouce en l'air
C'est les meilleures récompenses que je peux avoir quand je fais des vidéos.
Passez un excellent dimanche.
Levez-vous, il est 11 heures, c'est l'heure
et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
TCHAO